you know the Flyers losing five in a row they're
outscored 27 to 12 giving up goals and not scoring
enough goals is a bad combination speaking
of goals it's Reinhardt for M the save this
at the beginning of games he jumps into the play
Reinhardt just throws the solad right at him and
almost jammed it in look at that what a beautiful
pass Mika got a little position he was looking for
a hooking call right after he took fly's going to
ride Sam ERS and goal it appears good or bad see
how it goes here is forsling getting one off his
glove veteran defenseman having a real good year
sealer Bing put it out in front stenin trying
to get to it he tracks it down at the goal line
de flad shot oh that one hit the post and then
another shot from the board stopped and if there's
132 and two in their last 17 games here's kachuk
with a Chance uron B off there's another quality
chance for holds in for kachu moves it up high to
mour Quick Pass to Bennett now the baners snapping
it around here's Veri in front Mika denied it the
net for the second time oh big ni's getting some
chances nice move by Bennett has kachuck at the
blue kachuck shoots that one high hit the referee
Puck Lo along the boards kachuck throws the body
lton picks it up and clears but possession right
back to the Panthers and here's barov all alone
moving in and he hit the post is is finding the
open man and that's why he just said Flyers got
caught on a bad line change and there's barkov
and look at the shot goes right [Applause] through
cam York on the shooting Nick cousins back in the
panther lineup Flyers hold in that's their first
real shot on ball another one kind of rolled on
stolar so not easy for stolar sitting there
all that time finally sees the puck he makes
the save here's another shot he got a piece
of it that flash physical against katees at
the end boards Heckman Larson gets a hole but
Billy works it back up high stick save by stolo
olar spent the allstar break at home in New Jersey
had a little surprise birthday party enjoyed that
cousins with a steal cousins looking puts it in
front londell is stopped at the net by ERS watch
as tippet turns the puck over there's cousins he
waits now for lundell wait wait and there's the
SAU pass londell got a stick on it a different
view right there lell was positioning inside
closing on them after they lost the five in a
row Panthers trying to strike first and a hot
power play barov rips one off her jumps high in
the air played around Veri picks it up RI moves
in RI shoots he scores part of Rey with a rocket
and it's one nothing whip it whip it real good and
that's exactly what RI does he loves to come off
and curl off that board barov ripped one up high
and the Flyers couldn't look at how it just opens
right up and BAGI takes that ice and he goes short
side top shelf right underneath the crossbar what
a beautiful goal for Veri and the Panthers have
a one- nothing lead and he can add fory as Welly
a take away this is Bennett shooting Ur made the
save as kachuck Walker now snaps on that hit his
own man in front conne conne good Hustle able to
keep this Puck going in the offensive zone kicks
it free Champs in front backhand shot stopped by
stolar gich in after it against zamula gajic got
it towards the front of the net kulakov has emman
Larsson with a wrist shot blocked away stenin got
it through to kulakov the big blast knocked down
in front and ERS makes the save Ney through the
body again Mika clears Reinhardt gloves it down
gets to the line taken away and connect he's
got to break away in against stars and stars
makes the [Applause] save and then right behind
them in that division Pittsburgh jersey two wild
card spots right now being held by Atlantic
division teams Tamp was behind the Panthers
in third then Toronto and Detroit save there by
ersen Rodriguez back in the play they got it to
Center sent back to the panther in Rodriguez it
just seems like he takes one in the face every
game whether it's from his own teammates or an
opponent so better start the opening two minutes
of the second period for the Flyers at least a
little bit of Zone time against the Panthers for
him chance here pass a by stolar on the Forster
shot from out high tippet jumps on the loose Puck
though York with a shot blocked away in front
hit his own man Flyers hold in here comes rist
thein cutting out in front of the backand stopped
Panthers do the job on the pead and again they do
not allow a shot on goal Philadelphia still has it
in the offensive zone though paling shoot saved by
stolar rebound out to stenin who clears onour
on the clear Panthers L looking for a change
here they got got some tired players on the ice
the neck knee Cuts in and fires big stopped by
stolar on conne again Walker trying to get free
Panthers didn't allow him to clear forgey again
controling forsling big blast save by Ur stenin
is back conne unable to handle that puck here
comes lomberg with speed flying in over the line
Ryan lomberg takes the shot ERS one nothing game
here oh tip it is open save by stolar and
then another one Anthony stolar is busy
here in the second period to stop of the
former Panther here's sanheim in deep the
defenseman looking in front Panthers have it
covered now sanheim comes in front and stolar
with the save and no rebound yeah they're
not giving they're not giving Florida just
those easy outs out of Their Own Zone and
hitting somebody in the neutral zone with
full speed kkny is in he shoots and he
scores and this game is tied Travis kkny
well kkny only had one goal in his last 11 games
the representative of the Flyers at the All-Star
game but we talked about him at the start of
the first period he is a threat every time
he's on the ice and he's got the talent look
at that stretch pass and just dumps it into the
middle and he was at full speed he came off the
bench and came into the pitcher there he is and
what a beautiful sauce pass there by farby and
he just with a nice touch hand the commitment
already from stolar one nothing Panthers
go up by two you never know how the game
goes kept it at a one goal game fori has the
panther goal takes a shot here and Ur made the
[Applause] save they remain
even look out far breaking in Saved by stolar as
he kicked it out oh fary put
on the jet get and he had a
[Applause]
chance poring goes across look out
nobody home Flyers is able to pick
it up it's katees on the backand to the
net and he scores and off the turnover
Philadelphia leads for the first time
tonight a sloppy Puck management by
the Panthers here and the Flyers take
advantage here's the crossy pass but it
was way in front from forsling to EAD and
now the Panthers are just fishing for the
puck there's the different angle of it poring
got a piece of it reinhardt's got to wait for
everyone to get on side final seconds and
the Flyers hold on for the two to1 win